let's ride twenty nine hundredths as a
decimal so we'll start with 29 over a
hundred and let's start breaking that
down until we can get to place values
because place values will help us to
convert to write this as a decimal 2900
sui can break that down into 20
hundredths plus 9 hundredths 20
hundredths plus 9 more hundredths is
equal to 29 hundredths so we've just
broken it down some here it's still
equivalent to twenty nine hundredths
we're just taking it apart trying to get
to place values going from there we can
simplify even more 20 hundredths can be
simplified we could divide 20 and 100 by
10 so we'll say two tenths plus nine
hundredths and now if you can hear the
tenths hundredths
these are place values we should
recognize from decimals so what we've
shown here is that 29 hundredths is
equal to two tenths plus nine hundredths
here we have two tenths which matches
two tenths and nine hundredths like our
nine hundredths right there and so we
can take those and think about place
value if we have our decimal let's first
put our decimal over here to the left of
the decimals our ones place value we
don't have any ones here so we'll put a
zero zero ones but the next is tenth
then we have our tents and we have two
tenths and after tens the place value
after tenths is hundredths and here we
see we have nine hundredths so we'll put
a nine in the hundredths place and so
down here zero point two nine or twenty
nine hundredths is equivalent to the
fraction twenty nine hundredths and just
listen to how those are said it's kind
of a clue that we did well
nine hundredths is equivalent to twenty
nine hundredths both the fraction and
the decimal are read the same way so
that's a pretty good clue that we
probably rewrote these correctly so zero
point two nine is equal to twenty nine
hundredths let's try one more let's try
something let's say maybe 50 maybe fifty
three tenths so again we're going to
break this down we'll have 50 tenths
plus how many more tents are left
there's still three more tenths and
again we can simplify we can simplify
this 50 tenths can be divided by ten so
instead of 50 tenths we'll say five ones
plus we still have those three tenths
and now we've got this to place value
five ones is five ones plus here three
tenths is three tenths so thinking let's
put our decimal over here to the left of
the decimals our ones and we have five
ones and to the right of the decimal is
tenths and we have three tenths so five
point three or five and three tenths is
equal to 53 tends to write fifty three
tenths as a decimal we will get five
point three because it was five ones and
three tenths which we showed right here
five and three tenths